my name is kti borner I'm a professor at
Indiana University and I'm a co-director
of the sea far McMillan multiscale human
program mapping the human body at
multicellular resolution is a Monumental
undertaking in order to really do it
across organs across Technologies across
Labs you have to really find a way to um
do something that uh really brings in
the entire Village and CA brings
together a very diverse set of experts
people which might otherwise not have
met and because of this I think you will
have uh developments which otherwise
would not have happened because they're
Innovative they're creative they're new
they are really U bringing data and code
and models and approaches and Concepts
from very different disciplines together
which ultimately uh gives us us a much
richer environment in which we can
operate and uh develop multiscale models
and maps and ultimately an atlas of the
entire human
body
[Music]